[Music]
right here hey no moments ever too big
[ __ ]
go pack go hardman fumbles the ball it's
recovered by buffalo look at me hey look
at me
hey we could be you you're gonna play
this game seeing football at its
greatest right now we still ain't played
our best yet nope
welcome to the playoffs baby hey these
games ain't for everybody's game for the
at least
just give it all you got championship
sunday man yeah
where else would you rather be right now
look at this
it just doesn't get any better than what
we're about to see we can't wait for
this game to unfold in front of our eyes
we know you feel the same way
there once was
soon may the buccaneers come to
challenge rogers jones and adams
this time last year the worst team in
the nfl
but look where we at now gonna watch out
for them holding cars right
oh enough in england great day for some
nfc championship game
gold pack golf let's go bugs we know we
want to go we want to go play at home
next week
we got to take care of the day if i make
this the packers are going to the super
bowl
afc championship game let's go let's go
the whole world watching go bills
the afc championship game the top two
seeds
the buffalo bills and the kansas city
chiefs
i know what time it is chief's kingdom
we know what we made of here we go
bill's mafia
afc championship
keep that camera on me dawg okay
that's what i work for that's what i
work for right here
afc championship man back to back to
back stay tuned
brady has all kinds of stuff goes toward
the end zone it's important
touchdown tampa bay by kevin
[Music]
baby
[Applause]
hardman standing in his 11-yard line
drops it pops it
bills ball on the three-yard line
[Applause]
all right
helping us to forget about that muff
punt hey hey
that's how you handle adversity let's go
we're rolling one at a time
do it again next play your next play
your best play
you just got to be ready to attack
outside one-on-one
brady goes for the deep shot he's got a
touchdown
scotty miller
scottie miller time baby let's go brady
is masterful
okay you know i got those babies we're
gonna find out a lot about ourselves
right here just cause we got that lead
on me we can't get more
here's my home for the touchdown
hell yeah wait a trusted baby
yo so i told y'all aaron rodgers gonna
have to put his cape on let's go
believe it aaron rodgers
[Music]
hey we got to get a stop right here you
should have a building today
he's trying to throw you all pictures
brady under center
he pop flies and it is intercepted again
that just starts to feel like a team of
destiny
tom brady knows that his night is far
from being over
eight years just to get back to here 7
41 to go in the game third down in gold
cheese boys
the bill season is over he's the
proudest i've been of this team
in almost 30 years
[Applause]
for sure for the city i go crazy man
that's what i do man
we doing again baby back to back amc
chance go to the super bowl again
[Applause]
can the packers get a score here and a
two-point conversion to get this thing
tied
with time initially steps up scrambles
throws late over the middle
incomplete my goodness aaron could have
up kick kick it wow who would have liked
to have seen them get it done there
hey we got three timeouts i'm a little
surprised they didn't actually go for it
on fourth down there
what you're taking the field wow i
thought that they would
go for it on fourth down me too
troy me too
who else would you rather have than tom
brady the greatest ever do it
third down in five with 48 seconds left
[Music]
he's got the first down and this game's
over
[Music]
he's coming home great playing bro
super bowl baby we made it history made
baby
we in there baby bro man i love you man
let's go one more are you at home
i really look up to you too man man keep
your head off
the super bowl baby how about it we've
only done this ten
times well a little different this year
yeah i say so
i got some real special come out for my
green bay packer fans hold on
the crew sailed up to lambeau field the
superbowls on our own home field
we'd be the first one of our kind we'll
take our rings and go
fresh out the smoke
[Music]
i am a fresh hot air we going to the
super bowl baby